voa vials stand for volatile organic  analysis and are designed for water  sample collection open top voa caps are  best used with auto samplers so that  enables it to easily pierce the septum  to reach the analyte our voa vial caps  come with ptfe silicone cap septa to  help prevent sample degradation the vile  shoulder slope is also optimized to  prevent air bubble entrapment voa vial  caps come with the numbers such as 24 to  400 with the first number meaning the  diameter size and the second number  being the thread size voa vials come in  amber or clear with amber highly  recommended for any light sensitive  analytes our vials are certified to meet  or exceed epa performance standards  standard volumes are typically 40 mil  but 20 mil and 60 ml options are  available upon request